[Music]
in this knowing then Spirit has
concluded the movement in which it has
shaped itself insofar as this shaping
was burdened with the difference of
Consciousness that is of the latter from
its object of difference now overcome
Spirit has won the Pure Element of its
existence the notion the content in
accordance with the freedom of its being
is the self-alienating self or the
immediate Unity of self-knowledge
the pure movement of this alienation
considered in connection with the
content
constitutes the necessity of the content
the distinct content as determinant is
in relation is not in itself it is its
own Restless process of superseding
itself or negativity
therefore negativity or diversity like
free being is also the self and in this
self-like form in which existence is
immediately thought the content is the
notion
Spirit therefore having won the notion
displays its existence and movement in
this ether of its life and is science in
this the moments of its movement no
longer exhibit themselves as specific
shapes of Consciousness but
since consciousness's difference has
returned into the self as specific
Notions and as their organic
self-grounded movement
whereas in the phenomenology of spirit
each moment is the difference of
knowledge and truth and as the movement
in which that difference is canceled
science on the other hand does not
contain this difference and the
canceling of it
on the contrary since the moment has the
form of the notion it unites the
objective form of Truth and of the
knowing self in an immediate Unity
the moment does not appear as this
movement of passing back and forth from
Consciousness or picture thinking into
self-consciousness and conversely on the
contrary it's pure shape freed from its
appearance and Consciousness the pure
notion and its onward movement depends
solely on its pure determinedness
conversely to each abstract moment of
science corresponds a shape of manifest
Spirit as such just as spirit in its
existence is not richer than science so
too it is not poor either in content to
know the pure Notions of Science in this
form of shapes of Consciousness
constitutes the side of their reality in
accordance with which their Essence the
notion which is posited in them in its
simple mediation as thinking breaks us
under the moments of this mediation and
Exhibits itself in accordance with the
inner antithesis
in paragraph 805 we get another really
important transition point and as Hegel
is going to say uh sort of
Correspondence between two of the things
that were particularly interested in a
galleon philosophy and one of them is
knowing or knowledge if you want to take
a more substantive the vicen right so
the knowing of who of spirit but also of
Consciousness self-consciousness the
phenomenologist who's been studying
along with Hegel these many different
Transformations going on and then
science Vision shop not a term that's
radically new at this point but we're
getting a much better
understanding of what it means in
relation to and he names the text here
the phenomenology of spirit right
so we're going to get a correspondence
between what is happening abstractly in
science visonshoft and what we have
traversed in this entire book in terms
of shapes of Consciousness Gestalt and
his before sign or in this case shapes
of spirit because Spirit has been using
and inhabiting these shapes to come to
understand itself through us through
through human beings in this entire
process of development so we're looking
at how Spirits knowing transforms or
better said reveals itself as also being
science as visenshaft at this final
stage and I do want to point out one
other thing before we jump into the text
something that's coming up about I would
say two-thirds of the way through this
he talks about
this also being a shape of Consciousness
right
um so you know absolute knowing is
itself
one of the shapes but it's it's a
different shape it's a final shape at
least as far as this text goes you know
we're going to talk about its location
and hegel's larger project so how does
this fit in with the science of logic
well that's that's a much bigger
discussion that has vexed uh many Hegel
Scholars and interpreters throughout the
years maybe even bothered Hegel a little
bit for all we know right
so let's let's take a look at what's
actually here in this very interesting
paragraph So he says in this knowing
Spirit
has concluded it's brought to a finish
the movement in which it has shaped
itself now movement in which it's shaped
itself Hegel actually uses the term
Gestalt in there and not uh just as a
verb but actually as as a noun it's it's
shaped itself in time space history and
then he says insofar as this shaping was
burdened with the difference the unto
Sheed distinction of Consciousness and
then here Miller offers a gloss of
Consciousness from its object and that
kind of makes sense I'm not super happy
with giving that gloss in part because
it makes it a little bit restrictive
what is the distinction yes
Consciousness is distinguished from its
object it's also a self-consciousness
distinguished from itself as we're going
to see in just a moment and from other
self-consciousnesses
so you know maybe we do we want to
consider those it's object I I don't
think that that really works here
but he says this is a difference that is
now overcome and over and over again in
this Hegel is going to be talking about
how this distinction this difference is
alcohol but right how it's being
sublated canceled overcome however you
want to describe it and it's going to
get a little bit more clear as we go on
so he says Spirit has won the Pure
Element of its existence it's Dawson
the notion the concept this is what
we've been seeking the entire time and
we've had all sorts of Notions along the
way to be sure but we've got to
distinguish between let's call them
lower case n uh Notions or lowercase C
Concepts which are not finished not
completely worked through and might
actually be given to us not through
thought or
um you know the concept itself but
through other modes of of uh thinking
acting feeling those sorts of things
lesser modes and hegel's point of view
think about the religion section we were
encountering the concept but we're doing
so in part through the mediation of the
community which is good uh and through
the image and through you know thinking
about our own relation to it in in the
cult the warship and through
representation or picture thinking for
Shalom right now we're getting getting
beyond that not in the sense that we've
all left it behind and imagine you know
just for a little bit of a digression
here
imagine a book that's filled with all
sorts of pictures and diagrams and
schemas and stuff like that and
um does auf haben mean tearing all that
out and replacing it with stuff up in
her head no you leave the book there but
now you've extracted from it what the
Fuller meaning it senses and you
understand your own relationship to it
and you understand the limited adequacy
of the pictures within it and we could
say the same thing for language too
right which is a much more flexible
medium than the visible signs and
diagrams and schemas and that sort of
thing even language has its limits but
you know we can overcome them and
incorporate that when we don't throw it
away we don't say well a verbal formula
no good get rid of it we don't like
definition but we understand
how and why they aren't the full picture
if we want to use a little pun here
right so he goes on and he says
the content in accordance with the
freedom fry height of its Bing sign is
what the self alienating self right the
Zeke and oysterenda zelps and so the
self that isn't just alienating but is
going outside of itself out into I mean
this is where we can talk about the self
and its objects that it's grasping
through its Consciousness right or
grasping Itself by looking at itself
from the outside self-consciousness
grasping itself in relation to other
self-consciousnesses perhaps even
grasping itself in terms of larger uh
societal cultural movements that it is a
part of right so this is all included we
could say in the self alienating self
that is the content and then we've got
this thing movement
right so he says uh the self-aliating
self or the immediate Unity of
self-knowledge knowledge of itself right
I am a self I know myself do I Know
Myself perfectly no as a matter of fact
I may need the mediation of somebody
else you know uh
a friend counselor a role model
therapist pick whoever else you want to
help me fully more fully I understand
what it is that I am as a self and then
he goes on he says the pure movement of
this alienation so be the movement
involved in this going outside of the
self becoming other to the self
considered in connection with the
content right so
in a way the content itself is not just
content because as we look at the
content it not only has this this you
know self-aliating thing oh that's
really cool but it's also got the
movement itself of that which is kind of
the content kind of not the content
right and he says uh this the pure
movement of this alienation considered
in connection with the content
constitutes the necessity the novemdkite
the why it has to be the way it is
the intelligibility for us as well of
this content and now he says something
really interesting
I mean the rest is interesting but this
I find really really interesting
the distinct content right the content
of what spirit is
as determinate
right so as
um not just any old abstract content but
as something that is go we go back to
existence right
um
is in relation
right is not in itself so this is not an
in itself something that is just what it
is and and nothing more it's in relation
to other things
in relation to what
well that's what we would expect to see
in relation to this in relation to that
and Hegel kind of leaves that open
and I think what we ought to do here is
interpret that as well you know
this is an important moment where we
realize that the content exists not by
itself but as what it is through its
relations to other contents right in
spirit
because he goes on and he says it is its
own Restless process now Restless
process unrest is a better way of
translating it it is this this not
staying still uh of what uh this
restlessness this
um uh not remaining the same thing and
he says it's supersession of itself
alphaben so that's where we get this
coming in and then he talks about
therefore negativity or diversity like
free being which we just mentioned is
also the self so the cell
is all these things negativity uh
self-alienating self by its very nature
right not in itself in relation all of
superseding itself these are all
involved at this stage in what it means
to be a self
at this point in the development of
spirit is he saying this about every
single self no unfortunately you know as
we know for Hegel
um the dialectical process leaves an
awful lot of selves behind at earlier
stages earlier shapes of Consciousness
in the dialectic and may not even extend
to all in the present of his own time or
in our time as well
there's a tragic element to hegel's view
on on history and human beings a little
bit of a side note there all right
coming back to this so he says
um
negativity diversity free being in this
self-like form
in which existence is immediately
thought now immediately thought not in
the sense of we immediately think of
existence existence is dozen thought is
good you know gdanka denkin and so we've
got these two put together as a sort of
an identity statement right existence is
thought at this point so we're not we're
not engaging in a lot of action that's
kind of behind us at this point so he
goes on and says
um
here we go in the self-like form in
which existence is immediately thought
the content
is the notion
it's all the grief
this is what you know one understanding
of the the notion we've been seeking
this entire time is and then he goes on
and we get this important transition
Spirit therefore having won the notion
achieved attained to the notion displays
its existence and movement in this ether
of its life and is
science Vision shaft now there's a word
here that we need to explain a little
bit and to clarify the implications of
so what is ether
you may think of ether as a quaint word
for gas that might get used for its
anesthetic properties and that's a later
term originally ether is
a Fifth Element a quintessence right in
addition to air Earth fire water in the
Greek thing there's sometimes they
postulated that it could be the the you
know medium or the basis of thought or
of the fiery stars above or whatever you
want right it was always conjectural and
by the time of hegel's writing ether now
is something that is being sort of you
know thought of as a medium for possibly
carrying things so it's not just an
imaginary notion or concept at the time
of Hegel it means something like a
medium and so it displays the spirit
displays its existence its Dawson and
its movement it's bavague in this ether
this medium of its life and is because
of all of this
science
so he tells us in this in what in
the moments of its movement
no longer exhibit themselves as specific
shapes of Consciousness as they were for
Spirit in this entire book
but since Consciousness is difference
has returned into the self over here
right
they are displayed as specific Notions
so you know specific determinate
later on he's going to talk about pure
Notions this is how science works the
Notions
are the content
and the thing we move between for
science
so this is good if you want to go on to
the science of logic or you know think
about some of his other uh discussions
as well that come about later so anyway
back to this
um as specific Notions but also as
something else
they're organic self-grounded movements
so it's not a purely static
schematic sort of well I mean think
about the the old caricature of Hegel
that that he does sometimes give a
little bit of um fuel for by loving to
do things in terms of Triads you know
thesis antithesis synthesis and then the
new the synthesis becomes a new thesis
for a new antithesis in synthesis this
is the way many people have
misrepresented hegel's thought and not
just hegel's thought but hegel's
thinking about thought and its
development it doesn't work quite like
that right
there is movement there is in fact
contradiction we're actually going to
end with gay gonzatz at the end of this
paragraph
which is being translated here as
antithesis rather than contradiction but
um things aren't quite so neat and
simple are they
never really in in Hegel or really in
any important thinker for that matter
all right back to back to the text
um so he says whereas in the
phenomenology of spirit and here he's
naming it does geisters right
um whereas in the phenomenology of
spirit each moment
is a difference of knowledge and truth
of vissen and vah height right so they
don't they don't quite match up right
there is a distinction between them and
we can say well what is truth for Hegel
truth is not just correspondence of
what's in our mind in our language with
reality it's how things actually hold
together we could actually go on further
and say you know because that's often
talked about as the coherence theory of
Truth as opposed to the correspondence
theory of Truth we could say that
hegel's understanding of Truth is a bit
more robust than a mere coherence theory
of truth it's not just that everything
hangs together in a totality and makes
sense with each other everything has to
be
worked through its contradictions so
that they can actually hold together and
not be entirely separate things that we
can concentrate on this one or this one
but not not both at the same time
so going on right
um
he says each moment is the difference of
the knowledge of knowledge and truth and
is the movement in which that difference
is canceled so how do we go from one
Shape Of Consciousness to the other
through a progression through actually
working through the difference between
knowledge and knowledge here could be
action by the way or could be desires
there could be willing it's being used
in a very broad sense and then truth
these are worked through there's there's
a cancellation an auf habong of their
difference their distinction their
ownership they're they're being
separated apart from each other
and we get to uh you know a resolution
and then we move into the next Shape Of
Consciousness the next section of the
phenomenology so just to take some
examples right think way back to the
Consciousness section which had three
main subsections uh sense certainty we
begin with what Hegel says listen
there's a great starting point we begin
with objects that we encounter in space
and time and we're not even thinking in
space and time although that's where
we're encountering them we're just
thinking wow water oh you know uh air oh
tree you know and then we start getting
a little bit more abstract with that we
start to realize that they are in fact
connected with space and time now here
and we realize that oh this is not so
immediate as we thought the truth of
these is not the same thing as our
knowledge our knowing of them how are we
going to bring these two back together
and then we get to
the next stage perception the thing in
its qualities right now we start to get
to things that are a bit more complex
and we can think about well what is a
quality what is an actual substance or a
thing and we work through that and once
again we see that the truth of it
doesn't map neatly onto our knowledge of
it and in order to get that truth we
have to change our knowledge right and
then we get to the one of the hardest
sections of the phenomenology force and
the understanding because we're thinking
about things no longer just as isolated
individual things with their property
let alone like immediate experiences
we're thinking about them in relation to
each other as governed by
laws moved by or expressive of forces
and we try to unify it as subjects with
our own minds or try to seek out that
truth again right and it's you know the
stuff that we go through with that we
wind up with worlds and all sorts of
very interesting interactions and
eventually we get a sort of
reconciliation
that's the way the phenomenology Works
according to Hegel okay so um
in the phenomenology of spirit each
movement is this difference and the the
overcoming or cancellation of that
science he tells us does not contain
this difference in the canceling of it
well now that sounds like oh science is
missing something science isn't quite as
good isn't quite as robust isn't quite
as well worked out as the phenomenology
of spirit it's kind of he'll use a word
abstract
and so maybe we're missing something as
we transition to science great to have
science but we got to leave all this
stuff behind now that's not really the
case science does not contain this
difference in canceling of it why
because
since the moment has the form of the
notion notice he's been using content
here now he talks about form uh it
unites the objective form of Truth
and the knowing self
in an immediate Unity
right
truth and the self truth and the subject
that is trying to attain that truth
through knowledge
have been brought together in science
science still has a subject but it's
being presented in a you could say I
don't want to say more objective because
that's geogen stenlake a more uh
uh developed
more individual independent
way
right and here is where once again he
brings up Notions
and uh he says that
um
the moment does not appear as this
movement of passing back and forth
from Consciousness or picture thinking
earlier into
self-consciousness and conversely on the
contrary it's pure shape
freed from its appearance and
Consciousness the pure notion and its
onward movement depends solely on its
pure
determinedness right so science is uh
doing something different
it's not
something independent of us
but you can think of it as a
transformation
and consolidation of our thinking that
all of the previous work and the
phenomenology has now prepared first
Hegel for and now us his readers as the
way Hegel would construe it I think
now he goes on and he talks about
each abstract moment of science to each
of these
corresponds a shape of manifest showing
itself Spirit as such so what do we have
here a correspondence between the
determinate Notions that are what
science is is trying to provide us with
a correspondence to shapes of
Consciousness shapes of here he says of
spirit Spirits shapes
so
this is very interesting why does this
correspondence matter because we want to
get from the phenomenology of spirit
ultimately into
science right the phenomenology of
spirit can't remain merely a
phenomenology in the sense of like
looking on to the process and saying aha
here's what came after this and this is
why things develop this way with a
certain necessity here's a complex
arrangement
we have to
uh however you want to translate it
supersede cancel transform raise to a
higher level Alf Haven we have to do
that to ourselves and our own knowledge
to transform it into
science
so he goes on and he says just as
spirits and its existence is not richer
than science it doesn't actually say
science there it just has a pronoun
referring to it it's not poorer either
in content so spirit in its existence
um
not richer than science that's good news
for science isn't it right because
spirit in its existence is about as rich
as you can get it encompasses everything
in the world so what does that mean
science Vision shaft should have all of
that content as well
right should it should be able to extend
to everything take it all in now of
course the way it presents it is not
just a big mass of like everything
scribbled down in journal after Journal
it's got to be organized it's got to be
thought through it's got to beholden the
essential moments of it have to be
pulled out and the other stuff has to be
left behind
but it goes on and he says
to new to know the pure Notions of
science once again determinate Notions
pure Notions that what it is that
science is articulating itself through
to know the the pure Notions of Science
in this form of shapes of Consciousness
constitutes the side of their reality
and here he is his reality not vehicle
which is kind of interesting
um so he's not talking about the
transition into like real life or
something like that he's talking about
how they present themselves to us in
ways that we kind of can't get away from
right and that is in the phenomenology
of spirit and he says in accordance with
their which with their Essence the
vision the notion the begife which is
posited in them in its simple mediation
as thinking dankan breaks asunder
the moments of this mediation and
Exhibits itself in accordance with the
inner antithesis the inner giganzots
we're not fully done here because there
is a contradiction there is a gag and
zots that now gets revealed but we're
really really close I think you can
sense it you might even be able to as we
say metaphorically smell it sniff the
path ahead and be like we are getting to
the end of this entire process and
indeed we only have three more
paragraphs to go at this point
so you know a lot has been accomplished
not only up to this point but especially
in this very interesting paragraph